you have failed this city
and you know why because they got away
from you we were never supposed to have
partners they was never supposed to be a
John Diggle a Felicity Smoak a team
arrow that was never supposed to be a
green arrow you have failed this city
probably my favorite scene from this
week's episode if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
everything this is obviously gonna be my
episode 18 video I also have a teaser
for season 7 Stephen Amell was just like
bored and answering questions and he
said you know what can I say about
season 7 well you know and I'll just
play the video here kid Ramos says what
can we expect in season 7 well assuming
Oliver survives you can expect alright
since this doesn't live that long and
since nobody will parse it and prove
that I said it I think that you can
expect a different hairstyle from Oliver
does that make sense a different
hairstyle all arounds an all-around
different hairstyle most of you probably
hear that in your mind immediately jumps
to Van Dyck but remember he talks about
his entire hair situation being
different so that means that either his
hair is gonna be longer on top of his
head or it's gonna be shorter like you
have to buzz it to be shorter but the
Van Dyke like I mean he talks about his
face hair so either he's shaving his
face or he really is going full beard
and I think that full beard would be
more likely than Van Dyck because if I
remember a long time ago he said that
they tried that like they costume tested
him to see what it would look like with
the Van Dyck and it just looked kind of
silly so they decided not to do it
because they wanted to do arrow as a
more serious show but just remember that
this isn't him promising that he's gonna
wear Van Dyck it's just him saying that
his hair is going to be drastically
different kind of winking at us from
behind the camera but he did answer a
couple questions on Facebook and said
that he couldn't really say much for the
beginning of season 7 without getting
into spoilers for the end of this season
because there's a bunch of people coming
back Sarah is coming back for the finale
Roy is coming back as a series regular
during season 7 I don't know if he's
coming back for the finale this year
though
there's just a whole bunch of stuff that
they've been talking about season seven
completely changing paradigm shift
things that you can't take back so just
expect it to be some really big twist
but top 10 WTF Easter eggs from the
episode Oliver on drugs for pretty much
the entire episode although you didn't
really realize what was going on till
after the first act so number 10 first
act Oliver like before you confirmed
that he's on vertigo is basically the
worst dad ever completely ruins Williams
science project storms off snaps at
Felicity you can kind of sense the
direction it's going when they have that
conversation like he's gonna do
something really bad what is he being
such an [ __ ] right now so number nine
he breaks up with felicity but she says
the later that wasn't the real her so
that's vertigo Felicity just telling him
that they should take a break number
eight Diggle might go to Argus that
actually sounds like a real thing like
I've been offered a job I might take it
number seven William is good at science
apparently he cloned a cabbage won
second place in his science fair maybe
with all the people on Team arrow or
associated with team arrow like William
is creating all this crazy new
cutting-edge technology maybe there is a
path to Oliver winning back his fortune
and getting his company back at some
point the whole idea of this Diaz twist
him taking over the city in like when he
says it's open season
tell everybody coming to Star City now
that Oliver Queen isn't mayor anymore we
can do whatever we want is that he's
rolling back all the progress that
Oliver made cleaning up the city since
season one so when he first came to the
city like they have all those references
like he's got the season 1 version of
the costume the season 1 version of
himself the city was crime ridden when
he first came back in the pilot so the
whole idea is the Diaz is turning the
city back into what that was but number
6 banging on the pipes welcome back
prometheus
he was so fun to have Adrian chase back
and he kind of gives him the season 5
speech again he's his own worst enemy
the person that he's never going to be
able to defeat turns out that the person
that hates the green arrow the most is
Oliver Queen himself if you've forgotten
how the vertigo works it's kind of a
twist on the idea of the Scarecrow's
fear toxin like he just starts
hallucinating everything but the way
they cut the hallucinations in the
transitions was perfect it was great
number 5 he hallucinates season 1 Oliver
in the season 1 costume there was never
supposed to
team arrow it was never supposed to be a
Felicity never supposed to be a Diggle
only the mission the list so that's what
he's referring to like when he first
came back to the city and just started
checking names off one by one number for
those two Laurel visions those are great
who's getting it Katie Cassidy playing
the preseason one version of herself
that's like all sunny and happy like she
hasn't been through any really hard
times you want me to help you pack for
the Queen's Gambit that line really got
me because I was like when is this
happening what's the timeline they also
brought back the mansion set or at least
a part of it Stephen Amell was on
Twitter saying I'll say it I want the
mansion back but there's only three ways
to do that one to do more hallucinations
like this two to do flashbacks or three
for Oliver to actually get his fortune
back and rebuild the mansion because
within the Canon of the show they burnt
it down between seasons a long time ago
so it doesn't even exist anymore in Star
City number three was that Richard
dragon hallucination which was great
because Richard dragon isn't really
talking to Oliver Oliver knows what he
wants and it's basically the exact same
thing that Prometheus told him I'm gonna
tear you down piece by piece tearing
down the green arrow and tearing down
Mayor Queen but then like later in the
episode the weird thing about this is
that Oliver just sort of absorbs this
because it's Oliver talking to himself
Oliver is Richard dragon in this moment
but then at the end of the episode the
real-life Richard dragon says the exact
same thing so number two he runs the
gauntlet at the police department in the
season one costume totally vicious is
amazing which is why people really love
the first couple seasons of the show
because he was so much more vicious and
so much more focused they also mirrored
that scene from season one where he
grabs Felicity in a zip line away Star
Wars style number one
Oliver is officially impeached and now
Quentin is acting mayor so mayoral terms
are typically for four years Oliver
became mayor at the end of season four
normally without stuff like this
happening he's stopped being mayor at
the end of season eight so no idea if
they're gonna go with a huge paradigm
shift in season seven if they roll this
back like if he becomes mayor again
after he fixes what's going on with Diaz
or maybe they'll choose to keep Quentin
in office and he'll just become the
de-facto mayor let me know in the
comments what you thought about the
episode
whether or not you think that Quentin
will still be mayor at the beginning of
season seven because I feel like that's
what you would do with his character
like what is he doing now all day every
day other than working in the office of
the mayor while Oliver Queen has been
falling into old habits by splitting his
time across all these things that he's
trying to do so wouldn't it make sense
that Oliver realizes that he needs to
make a change and stop being mayor or
stopping the green arrow and it's a
pretty safe assumption that he's not
gonna stop being the green arrow so
what'll happen is is there's new flash
that I have to post this weekend we
found out what the title of the finale
is and there's a whole bunch of stuff
going on with godspeed in the flash
family in the comics so I'll do video
for that there's more Avengers posting
soon click here for that brand new flash
trailer and click here for a brand new
infinity war thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight